you've been performing since childhood
yes and I'm curious you what kind of
stuff for you did you like to do when
you were a kid did you did you perform
for your parents it was a lot of like
performing in the basement nothing was
professional it was I wasn't a kid who
was like good with the outdoors like you
put me outside it was like rashes and
allergies so it was like a lot of me in
my basement with my brother
like whatever musical we saw we would
recreate it in our basement and my
parents were very big on like as long as
it was for art's sake there was no like
we could see anything no matter if it
was inappropriate for us or not
so the first musical they took us to his
Chorus Line which it's not the most
appropriate of musicals for like an
eight-year-old so we saw that and we did
it in my basement oh you did you like
learn the soundtrack I learned it
word-for-word
and the song that I decided was gonna be
my torch song was tits and ass which at
ease you're eight I'm eight and my
parents like that's fantastic
but then like what I wanted to do it
like for the school talent show all of a
sudden they were like no no no you can't
do it I was like what I killed it in the
basement why can't I do this out and
they like like they shut that down but I
did it in a basement constantly the
neighbors like one by one stopped I
thank you you you brought a tape this is
you performing tits and ass yes and this
will be used in court let's take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
I was not picturing I was not picturing
an unfinished beat so that's a
crawlspace yeah that looked like Gitmo
yeah you're gonna do that number and my
favorite is the dog whenever a dog walks
through any situation I'm over gay
you